the feud between the uk and france over
fishing rights escalated
after french fishermen threatened to
blockade jersey's main port
in response two royal navy ships were
ordered to waters off the island
on wednesday night the pm spoke to
jersey's chief minister
and the minister for external relations
and in a statement downing street said
the prime minister underlined his
unwavering support for jersey
he said that any blockade would be
completely unjustified
as a precautionary measure the uk will
be sending two offshore patrol vessels
to monitor the situation
france accuses jersey of imposing extra
conditions on fishing licenses
which it claims is in breach of the
brexit agreement
but jersey authorities say that some
french vessels simply didn't have the
correct documents to get their permits
we believe that the licenses we've
issued
are respectful of the brexit agreement
the question is whether those french
vessels
have provided the full amount of
evidence that they need to
uh to respect their historic rights in
some of those boots it's now
become apparent that they've not
provided all of that evidence and
we are absolutely prepared
to give those vessels extra time to
provide that evidence
on tuesday the french maritime minister
threatened to cut electricity supply to
jersey
which gets nearly all its power from
france but island authorities say
that's likely an empty threat because
they have a commercial contract with an
energy company
and could fire up the island's own power
station
but this row continues to brew and it
seems that
neither side is willing to back down yet
milana vaselinovich sky news